fancy is heavy it is quite heavy
it's very weighty so both of these
things are the same you know kinds of
batteries in them but the elites way way
heavier I'm not sure if that's a good
thing or not the grips on the back very
like luxurious it feels great it's
really smooth it's tactile on the back
the layout and the ergonomics of the
elite are kind of the same but the
rubber texture stuff definitely improves
things a lot actually neither of these
controllers feels as good as this
controller see the d-pad also is much
nicer like the last clicky feel the
quickness of the bumpers of way better
than these guys there's no sort of fight
in the joystick or the triggers they're
very quick to respond
joined us yank it out oh wow that's
really cool yeah that's really easy to
take off like alarmingly easy oh my god
this thing is crazy it doesn't feel like
they're gonna fall off during gameplay
like even if I like I'm just like really
wedging it against this side it doesn't
actually come off unless you actually
physically pull it out like that yeah I
really don't like concave film sticks
Klee you just feels like gonna slip off
in the entire time I think these are
actually better than the ps3 ones I
don't like it it's too big I honestly
don't know why people like on kids on
sticks this smooth
and less robbery therefore less likely
to stick to my fingers my the distance
between my thumb and the rest of my
group is not big enough for that to be
comfortable I feel like I'm falling off
it I definitely can't see myself using
these at all
these are really high okay they're
slightly taller
I see wow they're really tall okay no
wonder Caillou's a look at hot I'll not
this isn't doing it to me these are way
too tall this is for man hands
no girl hands this is a huge you need to
kind of push further out to hit the edge
of the analog range feels like it's
going to take me to moments of moving in
a direction like the turn speed slows
down you can definitely achieve more
gradual to turn with the right
thumbstick is the tallest stick which
may be what you want maybe not it just
so happens that for me these are really
tall and really hard to get on top of I
think personally I'd run a tall bump
stick on the right I'd use a small one
for the movement so like move in will be
quick but when I need to aim I can like
so slowly pan if you were a guy and you
had big a hand I mean it would have been
a nightmare using a ps3 controller
because that thing is freaking tiny so I
can totally see the point
so these wall switches next to the
triggers stop them from kind of going
down so far before they actually
activate so kind of like a hair trigger
mode I guess oh I like that a lot that's
actually a look better especially like
if you want to play like MLG styles
that's pretty cool I mean there's less
effort involved it was a lot of effort
involved in pulling your finger down so
obviously this is way better for FPS
games we need to fire a shot up really
quickly you don't want to depress it as
far I think I like him on all the way
just because it's it just feels better
pulling the triggers all the way down
can you swap the d-pad out let's come
off oh my god
oh it's magnetic that's nice so this
circle d-pad kind of makes it more like
the 360 pad which is it's not as bad as
that but it is still doesn't feel like
there's any precision feels funny
I mean I guess they kind of want that
for fighting games so you can do like
half circles easy to do 360 motions
really easily if I was playing Street
Fighter on this I would be whipping
everything if I was gonna play funny
game I'd probably prefer to use an
arcade stick I don't like this oh my god
just in case you didn't have enough
buttons on your controller here are five
more okay darling
so each of the paddles by default is
mapped to a face button so that means I
can shoot and reload like that so what
one of them is X not that one not that
one I don't know I feel like it's too
many ones to remember now it was like I
have my finger on H and it's like wait
what does that one do again should a
bunch of guys and then reload while
turning around which is kind of cool I
can just check on the white what's
behind me yeah okay oh wow oh that's
kind of cool like the idea of like
always having your finger on the one
both some six and still having access to
all the functions and really good
there's a lot going on in this
controller right now I'm not a big fan
of the paddles the option is nice to
have maybe like if I was going to map
each one to an item that would be handy
I think my ideal setup would be like hey
trigger on the right for sure I probably
use the Rays won the race thumb stick on
the right hand side and maybe only have
a couple of paddles for likely loading
and jumping it's definitely a solid
controller but I mean like I don't think
I can go back to a normal
one controller after using it the little
things are really cool like the petals
and that raised some sticker really cool
and entry difficult ooh I don't think
I'd use all the bells and whistles my
favorite thing about it is just that it
feels good but I would like that to be a
ps4 version probably if they had a
version that was just the sweet tactile
back that just just feels a bit better
without all the bells and whistles of
the plugging and stuff at the back and
changing how much the triggers move
that's something I might be interested
in it's not really a super essential
immediate purchase but it's definitely a
nice to have like an heavy control
you